[Music]
hey guys welcome back to 86th floor I
think he's great now and I'll let you
take it Anthony
okay Tony's on the 86th floor of the
Empire State Building wants the tallest
structure on earth but eventually
architects and engineers in New York
City and other countries figured out
ways to take construction to even
greater heights so some of his CBS News
colleagues from around the world tried
to one-up him greetings from the Willis
Tower in Chicago
which stands 275 feet higher than the
tip of the Empire State Building
Tony you may have the observation deck
but we have the ledge and this is not
for the faint of heart this glass box
extends four feet from the 103rd floor
of the Willis Tower
that's 1,350 three feet above the Windy
City and I dare you to look down hello
from across the pond in London England
where I'm hovering in this helicopter at
the same height as the Empire State
Building which is around 450 feet taller
than that building right over there that
is the shard an impressive building
which is covered in 11,000 individual
panels of glass this is essentially a
vertical City you have a hotel you have
restaurants you have bars you have shops
all topped off by this 72nd floor
sightseeing deck Nihao hello from
southern China for truly heavenly views
you've got a head east nine of the
world's top ten tallest buildings are
right here in Asia including that this
is the ping on Finance Center inch
engine at 1965 feet it's the world's
fourth tallest building it's also 500 11
feet higher than the Empire State
Building hang on translates to safe and
well how you wish you might felt after
looking all the way down back to earth
Bonjour from Paris France where the City
of Light sets the standard for great
sights at great heights I am standing on
the iconic Eiffel Tower which is
actually celebrating its one hundred and
thirtieth birthday this year some people
braving the cold and the rain to capture
some of these views here too
you know this building was the tallest
building for a staggering 41 years
before the Chrysler Building came onto
the scene in 1930 and then just one year
later another building took over that
title and Tony you are standing right on
top of it back to you